what are the things that predict whether
a relationship is going to work or be
happy and what are the things that sort
of Herald the disaster and in a
relationship
now one of the things that Bob and I
found right away is we just looked at
how
positive people were when they talked to
each other how affectionate how much
they're left together
um interest in one another curiosity
versus hostility anger you know
contempt sadness and disgust and we just
took a ratio of how many seconds of
positive devotion was were there
compared to negative emotion and we
discovered that the Masters even in
Conflict had five times as much positive
emotion as negative
whereas the disasters that ratio of
positive to negative average 0.8 is just
a little bit more negativity and
positivity so that was one of our first
discoveries and then we asked are there
some negative things that are more
predictive than others and we came up
with the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse
and Julie can explain what that is if
you want okay sure
um so these are the great big predictors
uh that can predict with over 90 percent
accuracy six years down the road where
are you going to be you're going to be
together happily with your partner
unhappily or will you already be
separated and divorced so the first one
is criticism and all of us are familiar
with that one there's no such thing as
constructive criticism none so when
you're putting minutes yeah when your
boss tries to critically uh
tell you feedback that's not a good
thing so what criticism means is blaming
a problem between you on a character
flaw of your partner so some examples of
that are you're so lazy you wouldn't
think of cleaning up the kitchen why are
you so uh irresponsible you're always
postponing how long it takes to pay the
bills you know what's happening with you
what's wrong with you it's one of the
great criticisms how are you supposed to
answer that you know it's saying you in
general are wrong so those are
criticisms and they hurt and the natural
response to that is the second Horseman
called defensiveness and defensiveness
we're familiar with too there's two
types one is whining like I did two pay
the bills on time or counter attack oh
yeah well when was the last time you
took the car in for repair you know it's
a counter attack so that's defensiveness
we have criticism defensiveness the
third is really the sulfuric acid for a
relationship it's called contempt and
what we mean by contempt is its
criticism too but from a place of moral
superiority so it includes some scorn
some disgust it's often expressed
through sarcasm
um like oh yeah I'm sure you picked up
the tickets ha you know contempt uh is
also name-calling all those horrible
names when we get very angry that we'll
call somebody could be mockery also ooh
you're so scared you know that kind of
stuff
so contempt is horrible and it not only
is the strong strongest predictor of
relationship demise
contempt also destroys the immune system
of the listener we discovered that in 15
minutes of conflict the number of times
a listener heard something contemptuous
predicted how many infectious illnesses
they would have in the coming years
right isn't that amazing so the immune
system suppresses of core or fights off
viruses colds flus tumors right and the
people who experience more contempt got
sicker over time so that was scary
finally the fourth Horseman is what we
call stonewalling and stonewalling is
when one partner completely shuts down
absolutely gives no response to the
person pretends they're not even there
we'll sit there but not give any nod of
the head anything verbal and that's
related to another Finding of ours about
uh physiological flooding which John can
explain but that what we call
stonewalling turning into a stone wall
in the middle of a conversation is our
fourth Horseman right so the the
physiology was very predictive and uh
and what we found was that when people's
heart rate gets above 100 beats a minute
or if you're an athlete 80 beats a
minute we start secreting our two stress
hormones cortisol and adrenaline and
that shuts down the ability to listen
people repeat themselves they think
they're being more persuasive when they
ill instead of you know talking quietly
they you know they really escalate their
behavior and they can't listen very well
they can't take in any new information
so the physiology is very important
because once people are secreting those
two stress hormones they you know the
conversation might as well be over
because it nobody makes any advance they
don't get creative as problem solvers
and so on yeah another word for this is
fight or flight
and I'm sure you know your listeners
have heard of that that's what we're
talking about
so when you're facing your partner
it feels like you're facing a
saber-toothed tiger
so in that context let's say you're in
the middle of uh I don't know a a an
argument with your partner and you're
finding yourself feeling those triggers
of fight or flights what do you do in
that context
in order to succeed or in order to fail
which one to leave
let's say let's say both what does
success and what does fail look like
like what what are the kind of options
that we have in this in this context
okay
so fail looks like staying there in the
conversation when you're in fight or
flight uh and what happens is you
escalate you get louder you repeat
yourself you know Ad nauseam uh you
start to move into more criticism more
contempt you can't think straight you
don't hear your partner at all so
nothing you say is a response to your
partner you're just yelling your own
point of view maybe maybe even getting
physical in the worst cases in a
successful couple here's what they do
the minute they sense that they're
getting flooded in fight or flight one
of them will call for a break and and
say when they ask for a break when
they'll come back to talk about the
conversation you know that topic again
so they'll say something like honey I've
got to take a break I'll be back in an
hour then let's talk again
that way they don't leave the other
person feeling abandoned and not knowing
if they're ever going to talk about it
again then when the partners separate
into separate quarters uh they each do
something that is self-soothing
not think about the fight because if
they think about it they'll stay
escalated but do something else distract
yourself read a magazine a book listen
to music meditation go for a run you
know all kinds of things you can do to
self-soothe take a bath and then come
back at the designated time when you're
calmer and a way to tell if you're
calmer is take your heart rate and if
your heart rate is back down to normal
then you're good if it's not back go
back to your partner anyway and ask for
more time
give a second time you'll return until
you can talk calmly with one another and
the conversation will look like you've
just had a brain transplant
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye